you might see properties like this
houses for sale grim looking properties
very basic kitchen
one bedroom flat
little garden okay
lots of potential potentially well this
exact flat in london was just bought by
my man mcgee what's happening bro
we're sitting in it right now
and how much do you pay for this flat i
paid for it
370. so he bought he bought this little
flat for 370 000 pounds
two-bedroom but you push the value up
yeah because you made it beautiful yeah
how much money did you spend on it i
spent 60k for the renovation it was ten
thousand stem duty holidays so all in
how much you have to buy 440 440 000
pounds now it's beautiful now it's great
what is the new value so the new value
at the moment by the bank is 600.
600 yeah so we will pull all the
investment out plus 10k
so all your money is coming out gonna
rent it out for how much 2200 it's
already rented it's already rented 2200
clean profit of a grand a month and also
you say we this dude what he does is he
pulls investors into his deals so
usually you don't even put your own
money in you put joint venture finance
in so incredible deal sounds too good to
be true however
we're in it show me around in order to
increase uh the value dramatically
obviously a new kitchen won't be enough
in new tiles yes so you need to
increase the the the square meters of
the house so what we have done we
changed the layout
we removed
the kitchen from the old existing space
that used to be in here so that was the
kitchen and you've turned that into a
bedroom yes and then you've
what was that in there so there was a
bedroom that we demolished and opened
the space hi so this was a big bedroom
so we we basically replaced the location
of the bedroom instead of being here we
put him there instead of the kitchen but
but then you've got this is the money
room i mean this is this is incredible
but then you've lost the bedroom yes so
then what did you do we went up to the
loft
show me upstairs let's see
so this before then this was the roof
yes and you've turned this into a
bedroom yeah nice
i can't believe you spent only 60 grand
because that kitchen i'm pretty sure
there's a marble kitchen i mean if you
call any other construction construction
company in the area it will cost
approximately 120
but that 60 is my cost price and that's
the add value i bring into my investor
on the table sure so although you've not
got the money to put into it necessarily
but you've got the skills to do the
reverb yes however you know it's
interesting a lot of people
have also got the skills to do the
reverb but they're working for 40 pounds
a day as a laborer yeah like you were
yeah so what changed how did you go from
a laborer on 20 40 pounds a day
with a bad back to this
big shot property developer with all
these people throwing money at yeah
massive action massive action every step
on the way you always plan what's the
next step and you're fighting to reach
them no matter where you are you always
need to have your next target yeah and
this is how i lived i lived from a
target to a target i used to live with
my wife in
his boyfriend and girlfriend in hmo in
one room yeah and then i told her that
in next time we will rent our own room
our house and rent the other rooms so we
won't need to pay and we've done it and
every every time we
we to climb the ladder it took
the next target yeah it's amazing when
did you decide that you wanted to be a
property investor so after the coffee
started i was sitting a lot of at home i
don't know what's really to accept with
all the contain and the lockdowns and
those kind of stuff
and i had a lot of time so i was like
okay if i have the time i better
sit and learn something so i was like
searching for flips or something to do
and you got you popped it popped up and
that's it since then i was like focused
on you and the way you teach and i
realized brr is my strategy because of
the build
and you always mentioned that it's
important to have a good builder and i'm
like okay i already have the good
builder with with myself yes
so it makes the whole process much much
quicker easier and
yeah also when i go for viewing i know
exactly what will be the cost of the
build straight away i don't need to call
anyone the thing is what you did was you
took you took the cards that you were
dealt with and you're like right i might
not have money i might not have this i
might have that but i've got the skills
to do the build
and then you applaud yourself to the
training
and and now
yeah three million pound property
portfolio financially free yeah uh it's
absolutely incredible so this was nice
talk to me about the ensuite
so yeah that's just an
out nothing special but do you do all of
your properties the same like you use
these tiles always yes at the moment yes
until i will be tired of it i mean it's
easier you have the whole plan already
there yes only to start design or all
those kind of stuff and do it quick yeah
cook come and talk me through the
kitchen that's got to be my favorite
room in the house
this kitchen i mean the floor as well is
this is this marble it's not marble it's
1200 by 1200 in porcelain
and i can get it
like in the range of the 40 40 pound per
square meter
making sure give me an idea how much how
much this kitchen how much it costs so
the kitchen with all the appliances
marble and melbourne on the splashback
so this is marvel yes
all together was seven and a half k that
this is like the cheapest you can find
in here in london i was surprised how
cheap
grand seems really cheap because i mean
and this is very different to the
kitchen so sometimes you know you might
you might see me sticking in my cheap
northern vitalettes this is really
high-end
i mean i like a kitchen like this for me
you know so
area as well what what street are we on
it's called flower lane flower lane yes
i like it it seems like a very nice
street big houses
is very fancy and we're looking at
houses of two millions here whereabouts
always what's this area called it's mel
hill mill hill in london yeah fabulous
love it
right and i had a piece of garden as
well okay
so so this used to be the kitchen yeah
what did you do with the exact life uh
we push the wall a little bit towards
the shower side yeah
make it a bit bigger than what it used
to be as a kitchen space yeah and it's
become a decent room
so it was a two bed
it was a two bedroom now it's a three
bed yes
it did have a rubbish kitchen now he's
got a big open blank kitchen so you've
added some serious that's how you added
the value yes
and was it freehold when you [ __ ]
that's a free odd and we are the only
thrills in here so um yeah we having
also the rare piece of the garden with
the storage there yeah
amazing so there we go
that's it i mean how much are some of
these houses selling for in this street
some of them are
two million pounds some of them are two
million pounds it's so easy to think
you've got no money maybe you live in
london where the houses are two million
pounds in the street can you really make
money in streets like this and the
answer is you've just seen me first yes
you can you want to see more videos like
this you can check them out right here
i've got a whole playlist a similar
videos of my students killing it doing
deals showing you around their deals
don't forget you can book onto the
property investors crash course i'll
leave a link in the description and of
course subscribe right over here i'll
see you next time
thanks man respect well done